you know we're learning ways to perturb
the brain and I'm just wondering do you
think someday that people will be sort
of enhancing kind of quote unquote
natural creativity to get people to be
more like what we think of as geniuses
or is that just not possible I love the
idea of the vision that there's a way to
to to bring out the genius in all of us
and I wish that there was a way that in
our educational system that we could
develop ways to promote creativity we do
actually we're pretty good at it but we
could be better that we can teach people
to take risk in education we could value
more the the the person that takes the
path that is not the common path I think
we as a society are pretty good at that
we could be a lot better mm-hmm
and I think that that's one of the
values of studying or thinking about
genius it's a way for us to think about
Chi let's let's get better this creative
business let's let's find that creative
spirit in all of us all right let's move
forward faster I think sometimes people
think about the brain as kind of a
shortcut to all these sorts of problems
you know if we just understand the brain
then we can just go right in there and
just fix things directly whereas it's
easy to forget that you know education
itself is alters the brain exactly I
think that you have to think about
brains in the context of our society um
one of the things about genius I think
is not just an individual just to bring
it's about opportunity it's about
somebody who has given the pathway to
actually make a contribution think of
our art musicians that most of us would
consider geniuses walk Beethoven Mozart
these are people that were put in
positions that allow them to
be creative the creative spirit comes
with many things other than just a brain
I think it comes from the opportunity it
comes with resources sometimes with an
attitude again I like the idea of not
thinking of it as something that that
targets an individual and separates them
but something that joins us together as
a quality that belongs to all of us hmm
well because it is true that when we
people talk about geniuses they are
other there there they're almost
freakish exactly and I think that that
attitude really deters people from
taking the risk when Sedona led sword
the genius term is often associated with
the person that really changes the way
we think it could give it something that
didn't exist before that changes the
course of our progress as some
fundamental way so that person by his or
her nature stands out and is different
and yet and yet all of us are different
in our creative sphere and that by
incorporating the creative person into
the mainstream it might be a way to
encourage more creativity in a way you
know you've been talking a lot about the
things that neuroscientists can't tell
us about genius we want easy answers and
and we think oh the easy answers are on
the brain and and you're kind of warning
us like well we neuroscientists we don't
know all that much the brain is a
complicated thing and it's in it it's a
social thing too
so I mean what do you think that
neuroscientists can do to help us
understand genius better I mean what
what are the kinds of studies that you
think would be like the best ones to do
to make us understand genius as you
think of it I think that in general the
study of individual differences is a
really interesting direction to take
differences in say there's some people
that have extraordinary memory
and we can design experiments to look at
the neural circuitry that's associated
with memory strategies and we learn
something about what makes one person
better at memorizing things than another
there are differences in on how how well
we do mathematics and how well we can
put things together and understanding
the rules for those differences is
important for example one of the things
that neuroscientists have taught us
recently is that the parts of the brain
are also richly interconnected and the
extent to which they are connected has a
great deal to do with function so we're
talking about say a patch of cortex over
here and another patch over here and
there are like cables joining them
together Andy and how well those
connections actually work on is thought
to give it a great deal to our
individual differences is it that some
people have more connections than others
or bigger connections or what's what
what are those underlying differences
well it's all of the above with some
cases the connections are actually more
richly innervated they're more simply
more fun in other cases they go to
slightly different places in other cases
they're just stronger connections which
is there's less noise in the brain I
mean all of those hypotheses are are
viable options because evidence for all
of them can it contribute to
considerable differences between
performances or one person or another so
if we if we start to get down to these
you know real kind of biological
components of you know creativity of
innovation and of you know ultimately
what we might call genius I'm wondering
how can we start to kind of figure out
like our geniuses just born or are they
aid or what can we figure can you figure
out like what the differences are you
know was was Einstein just a blank slate
when he was born and he just happened to
have a really good math teacher in first
grade I mean what you know how do those
connections what do we know about how
those connections develop in children
and teenagers as in adults and you know
how the genes play a role in all that
that really is the $64,000 question and
it is the question we would like to
answer how does the brain do it and how
do we help the brain do it better I
think that your question really raises
another really important point and that
is how much bigger our questions are
than our science our methodology we need
a genius to figure because we need to be
able to answer those kinds of questions
faster and answer them better and we
need to apply them to our lives
you